the twins face somebody buck with whom
they are
intimately familiar in jose barrios
absolutely barry has been 10 years in
the twins organization his only other
major league team and you see this will
be his 30th start of the season
for burritos has been his 10th start
since coming to the blue jays and he has
had a dramatic impact on the jay's
overall rotation
and a weak ground ball hit towards
second and a nice way for barrios to
begin his afternoon
and the batter is byron buxton
now buxton drives it to the gap in right
center field
and over the wall for a double and
buxton teeing off on the first fastball
driving it to the gap for an extra base
hit buckston over to third and once
again a very nice ovation for josh
donaldson
[Applause]
little pop up on the infield short hop
simeon throw to first in time
boy a tricky play up the middle and a
nice job by marcus simeon to make that
play and keep the twins off the
scoreboard starting pitcher stats
brought to you by home furniture luke
farrell first start of the year he has
some starts and pass you see at the
bottom there they're gonna let me see
how see if they can get two maybe three
innings if he keeps the pitch count
under control their twins are going with
the opener and a bullpen game today
another breaking ball and a good one
farrell with a strikeout so a runner at
second with a one down and here's
vladimir guerrero jr
he hits a screamer off the glove of
gordon in the left simeon rounding third
heading home an rbi single for guerrero
and a one to nothing lead for the blue
jays rbi number 105 for vladimir
guerrero jr
one out one in one back on here's beau
bechet
right center field buxton back and it's
gone
bow bushing with number 26.
a two run home run to right center and
it's an early three to nothing lead blue
jays have struck for three here in the
first and they're looking for more with
runners on it first and second and still
one out
this one's into right center field and
that ball is going to get down
tay oscar will get the wave and coming
to score around a third dickerson rbi
single goriel four to nothing here's
breivik valera hitting at the eight spot
there's a bouncer to the right side and
that's going to skip through into right
field
polanco couldn't get there it'll be an
rbi single for valera it is five to
nothing
to center where buxton awaits fighting
the sun a little bit
that ends an unsightly inning for luke
farrell with the blue jays striking for
five
just 222 on the season but 29 home runs
the 2-2
strike three call got him with a
curveball cenote goes down looking it's
the first strikeout this afternoon for
jose barrios jake cave the left fielder
to the plate hitting just 188 on the
season
and a ground ball to simeon and no
damage done with the air
a man left onto the bottom of the second
five-nothing blue jays here comes
vladimir guerrero jr who's attempting to
be the youngest triple crown winner in
major league history oh one swinging a
smash inside the third base bag past the
dive of a rise and up the line
guerrero speeds around first he's
trucking to second
he's two for two with a single and a
double already
and there are two down and now hernandez
and hernandez upset that he didn't do
more with that pitch
molanco squeezes it and vincent does a
nice job pitching around the one out
double one up one down here in the third
inning five nothing toronto louisa rise
at the plates of the pitch
roll towards the middle of the diamond
reaching out buchet's got it spins
around 360. buddy on the first base in
makes the stretch to get the out boy
boba's shed the last couple of days
using the glove and turning in his best
defensive plays of the season one down a
man on twins down five nothing here is
ray vic valera
score it six five three double play ends
the third inning
it's still five done in toronto three
four and five coming up locko donaldson
and kepler
polanco waves at a change-up down and
away second strike out of the afternoon
for burrills here's donaldson
oh donaldson's hit by a pitch
maybe in the right forearm right wrist
something like that up here
i don't know if he had breaking ball in
the back of his mind as well
that got him real good on the wrist
donaldson
no i'm not leaving well this is where
gordon in his rookie season has been
really good two outs runners in scoring
position nick is hitting almost 4 40.
lying down the left field line could be
trouble and it's not going to be caught
guriel couldn't come up with it two are
going to score twins are on the board
and now trail five to two
opposite field double for gordon the
pitch
strike three call got him with a curve
on the outside corner marios gets cave
looking to retire the side a two-out
walk to bring up vladimir guerrero jr
up the middle another base hit
simeon will stop at second guerrero is
three for three
and mania finally gets his third
strikeout but it took a while looked
like he might have an immaculate inning
and in the end all that really matters
is the blue jays didn't score
oh two swinging a miss
got him with a curveball strikeout
number five for jose barrios donaldson
drifting away at second one two swinging
a miss
ceno goes into the glove strikeout
number six for jose barrios who's been
fantastic again six innings of two-run
ball fired against his former franchise
valera jansen then springer and a 1-2
swung on and hit into shallow center
field bucks that comes in dives and
makes the catch
byron with a tremendous catch racing in
with a dive at the end and we'll check
and make sure he's all right that's what
cave is asking him right now well now
you've got to face
vlad jr with runners on first and second
no ball hit sharply right up the middle
and standing there as polanco to end the
inning a scoreless six we also have
every opportunity to finish seven
innings he's got two outs already and
now he'll pitch to rorvette
and driven to right roarkvent taking a
breaking ball
and hitting it out a home run for ben
rortvedt his third and it's a 5-3 game
and that was a bomb and it's also the
last pitch that jose barrios will throw
today but another very good outing and
remember against his former team
fastballs and change-ups from richards
the pitch there's a fast ball and it's
popped up
on the right side simeon trotting next
to guerrero simeon calling and catching
to retire the side and the new pitcher
on for the blue chase looking for the
save today the big right-hander jordan
romano
slider grounded to first guerrero's got
it and that'll do it the blue jays beat
the twins five to three they win the
series jose barrios gets a win against
his former team
and the blue chase have now won seven
consecutive series
and 18 of their last 22 games